so so so
I would argue back to 1920 because we
did have the Roaring 20s and around the
20s was when women got the right to vote
and a lot of times this is painted as a
good thing why wouldn't women get to
vote I mean we were just so oppressed
throughout all of history but then you
find out half of men have a job that
runs the infrastructure they pay 70 to
80 percent of the taxes
um they only seven percent of women have
infrastructure jobs they do the hardest
most dangerous jobs in society and women
there's more women so they're the
biggest single voter group so women have
more influence in politics than men and
you start to realize that who gave women
the freedom without the responsibility
and encourage
um instead it used to be that you would
get one vote for each family 85 percent
of people were married now they give two
votes